لم يكن من المفترض أن ينتهي الأمر
على هذا النحو على الرغم من سنوات من التحذيرات من أن
الولايات المتحدة ستنهي يومًا
ما مهمتها في أفغانستان.
1993 عندما كان
يبلغ من العمر 32 عامًا يسير لأسابيع للوصول إلى
بر الأمان في باكستان ، ثم انتقل في النهاية
إلى إيطاليا هذه المرة ، أُجبر على
المغادرة ، وعاد في عام 2006 مع
وكالة التنمية الإيطالية لإعادة بناء
بلاده ، وعملوا في
البنية التحتية والطرق التي قاموا ببنائها في
المستشفيات  والطواقم الطبية المدربة
هي السنوات العشرين الماضية الضائعة
، ليس الأمر أننا فقدنا كل شيء
ولكن الطريقة التي تخلينا بها عنهم هذا
الأمر أكثر صعوبة وأكثر إيلاما لقد
فعلنا الكثير من الأشياء ولكن لا ينبغي
لنا أن نتخلى عنها بهذه الطريقة أريانا
بريجانتي هي  نائبة رئيس
الوكالة الإيطالية نوفي أونلوس التي
عملت في أفغانستان على مدار
العقد الماضي لتمكين المرأة ، وأنشأت المجموعة
مدرسة لتعليم قيادة السيارات للنساء في كاب  ul
ووفروا خدمة نقل مكوكية حتى
تتمكن النساء من الانتقال من العمل والمدرسة إلى المنزل
بأمان ، لقد كان جيلًا متفائلًا
وأعتقد أننا فقدنا أنني أعني
الأشخاص الذين كنت أعمل معهم
لفترة طويلة وحتى الأشخاص الذين
تديرهم مؤسستي  لإجلائهم
يائسين لا يعتقدون أن
هناك مستقبلًا في أفغانستان بعد الآن أمينة
ليس اسمها الحقيقي يعمل في نوفي أونلوس
حاولت ثلاث مرات الوصول إلى
مطار كابول قبل أن تستخدم أخيرًا
العلم الأحمر للإشارة إلى الجنود الإيطاليين الذين
أحضروها  إلى الأمان تخشى على
من تركتهم وراءها لكنها تعلم أن
عملها لم يذهب سدى ،
أنا فخور طوال الوقت بكل
الأعمال التي قمنا بها بمساعدة
قائمة النبيلة لمنظمتنا التي قمنا
بها هناك منذ أن كانت جميع مشاريعنا
المتعلقة بتمكين
المرأة وتعليم المرأة وتطورها
كابتن لوكا من القوات الجوية الإيطالية
حلقت أول مهمة إخلاء إيطالية
من كابول في 15 أغسطس
على الرغم من أن الكثير قد تغير منذ
ذلك الحين مع الأمن  تفجيرات
انتحارية مميتة ، لن ينسى أبدًا
الأشخاص الذين أحضرهم إلى بر الأمان أو أولئك الذين
تركهم وراءه
، كان ذلك يمثل تحديًا للجميع ،
لكن عندما تهبط أخيرًا
وتسترخي ثانية واحدة فقط تنظر إلى هؤلاء
الأشخاص في أعينهم هنا تشعر  مثلما
فعلت شيئًا جيدًا جدًا ،
ويمكنك حقًا
رؤية الطوق في عيونهم كما تعلم
، لقد كانت رحلة طويلة للجميع
ولكننا الآن وصلنا إلى المنزل وهم في
طريقهم نحو شيء
جديد نوع جديد جدًا من الحياة
كثير من هؤلاء